Ron desantis's wife Casey DeSantis is
stealing Donald Trump's they came to me
with tears in their eyes routine so
DeSantis is already stealing the Joe
Biden basement line from Trump Casey
DeSantis is now stealing these stories
just as a reminder Trump often tells
these stories you know they came to me
they said sir and they were crying these
were big strong generals and then they
said uh we we don't have any we don't
have any bullets left Obama left the
cupboards bear Obama
and we always wonder are these stories
real I think the answer is probably not
now Casey DeSantis is taking a shot at
one of these stories like I have the
responsibility to come out here and say
this because I see him in front of the
cameras and I see him at home behind the
cameras and I see him with his kids six
five and three he never changes he never
wavers he never backed down he always
always stands up for what's right he
does not take the path of least
resistance he doesn't cower and it
really is refreshing to see that
somebody is standing up for what is
Right standing up for the rights
Liberties livelihoods and happiness of
the people that he was voted to
represent and that was true in Spades
when you saw kovid here we go I can tell
you stories of moms in the midst of
coven single moms coming up to me with
tears in their eyes yeah because they
didn't know how they were going to be
able to put food on the table for their
kids they didn't know whether their
children were going to be able to get an
education to be able to live up to their
god-given potential but they they were
crying they would go to they weren't
even going up to Ron DeSantis they were
going up to Casey DeSantis With Tears in
their eyes and crying listen is it
possible someone cried in Casey
desantis's presence
during covert I mean sure uh do we in
general believe that everybody is
constantly crying in front of
politicians who clearly don't care about
them I I struggle to believe that this
is a legitimate story let me know what
you think